non poteva non fare questo video è
giunto il momento ragazzi copiare pd
paio negli ultimi tempi di è stato un
casino non posso più copiare più di
python fare di forze mie
che peccato anche perché prima era prima
era più facile cosa sta succedendo sul
web e in questo periodo in questi anni
tra l'altro perché non ho mai parlato di
sta roba però lo so il motivo ma ogni
anno dei meme italiani fanno giro del
mondo e non so perché non so perché
l'italia è famosa nel mondo per imeem e
ve lo giuro non capisco il perché qual è
il motivo il meme che è esploso nel 2018
in questo momento ma in tutto il mondo
forse voi neanche lo sapete però c'è un
bel italiano che sta spopolando di
brutto ed è questo qui o mio dio li e
spaghetti non aveva poi scusami noi
italiani all'estero siamo visti proprio
come ci prendono nei man
sembriamo dei pirla ai loro occhi quando
parliamo perché facciamo tutto così con
le mani sono usanze diverse è vero
l'america è diversissima da l'italia il
giappone è diversissimo dall'america
addirittura quando in giappone un
giapponese aveva visto la mia foto su
instagram che tipo facevo così no io
faccio sempre così però in giappone se
fai così vuol dire una roba se fai così
vuol dire un'altra addirittura fosse una
di queste due era un insulto tra l'altro
come persona ho mandato a [ __ ] i
giapponesi cose strane che gli italiani
fanno va bene questa ragazza che ci
prende come esempio per farci un video
innanzitutto discutiamone il fatto che
lei ha le views perché se le merita se
le mie ha talento cose strane che gli
italiani fanno vai vostra c cara
e basta in america la porzione del pasto
più importante della giornata quindi
cosa mangiano le uova al bacon cose che
voi magari non mangereste mai a
colazione mentre noi italiani di versi
strani e bastardi mangiamo il caffè e
alle brioscine insomma le cose dolci e
basta ma essendo stato all'estero vi
dico la verità dio tipo il bacon la
mattina lo mangio indice proprio però io
ho visto gente che la mattina tipo si
mangiano la pasta cioè non puoi
mangiarti la pasta la mattina
addirittura londra neanche 10 chissà
quanto lontano a londra quando era
andato in vacanza lì la mattina si
vedevano il cesr loro hanno il succo di
pomodoro
magari lo beve tè anche voi per carità
non è che sta dicendo che fa schifo a me
fa schifo ci aiuta
aprite la scatoletta dei sughi pronti e
verrà bevete così al mattino come file
avere 216 mila iscritti davanti ragazze
[Musica]
presto prima che parla lei c'è questa è
una roba all'estero non hanno il bidet
cioè all'estero non si lavano all'estero
cagano si puliscono e basta non si
lavano il culo trani giappone che li ti
sparano l'acqua direttamente nell'anno
quando lei sta spiegando che cos'è un
vide la gente non sarà tutto sei un
video per farvi capire qual è il
problema non è lui che ha problemi e
siete voi che dovreste pulirmi il culo
bene ogni volta che vi e pulite cieche
che i discorsi di merda andiamo avanti
per cortesia ciao zio minchia io faccio
youtuber come lavoro faccio i video
questi video così è
porca vacca io non faccio un cazzo da
matti mi sveglio a registro la gente mi
vede o minchiata non che cazzo capisci
pronta gesticolando anche lei e non so
se state notando un altra roba ormai lo
spiego io cosa sta dicendo vaccini anche
vede perché è un catino me non c'ho
voglia di mettere sottotitolo pigro ok
un altra roba che gli italiani fanno e
che quando salutano la gente se danno
erbaceo mamma ciao bella negli altri
paesi questa roba non la fanno
se andate all'estero e volete salutare
qualcuno non gli date i baci sulle
guance perché lo vedono come se si
stesse provando noi italiani lo facciamo
perché abbiamo poco tempo per limona
quindi tra un testicolo e l'altro tra
uno spaghetto l'altro dobbiamo trovare
il modo di scambiarsi gesti affettuosi
un allora cediamo al bacio anche quando
non serve ok
l'unico che fa interessante
se anche voi avere i cari avete un po di
roba negativa di cui parlare
no facciamo riferimenti per carità di
dio
le donne americane verso le donne
italiane i sottotitoli d'italia re
attenzione grazie mi hai risparmiato le
dtt ha mostrato che le donne americane
siano alfa fine si grazia di noi
c'abbiamo alfa uomo e browser al canape
sfondi sì è vero le ragazze italiane
sono molto più difficili da agganciare
perché of iron youtube oppure devi
essere o benji o fede se no non è un
casino non prossima è veramente un
casino ragazzi io direi che facciamo un
video anche sulla differenza di capelli
tra gli americani e gli italiani guarda
in casinò comunque i regali dico
l'italia nel mondo è vista se con tutti
affascinati dal liceo dovunque sono
andato nel mio percorso da quando ho
iniziato a viaggiare un po tutti molto
affascinati dall italia però prendono
degli stereotipi tipo quella del cibo
degli spaghetti tacet mai spaghetti
oppure dei gesti le prendono proprio
come me me c'è l'italia in questo
momento è famoso anche per il meme e
questa cosa è strana c'è veramente
troppo strana però è importante che se
ne parli
niente ragazzi poi magari farò un video
sulle strane io farò un video sulla
stranezza americane però devo fare i
sottotitoli poi non scherzavano ragazzi
io vi lascio che cioè i maccheroni che
sono quasi pronti di là spero che vi sia
piaciuto
cosa si vede il momento non mi piace
anche vari iniziale santo resi schiavi e
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo meme da
ragazzi
[Musica]